bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france françois grosdidier
je le disais le maire de metz qui a
demandé ce que les vacances scolaires
commencent dès ce soir en moselle au
lieu de la semaine prochaine il n'a pas
obtenu pour l'instant de réponse dans
l'attenté d'une réunion mathieu risque
il faut fermer les écoles tout de suite
mais clairement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est au pied du mur la situation est
devenue très préoccupante et on est
arrivé à un stade où a plus le temps de
se poser des questions parce que le dans
les établissements scolaires le virus
est très présent et c'est pas uniquement
dû à des modifications du protocole
comme on essaye de nous le faire croire
on constate que nous sous le terrain dé
remonter tous les jours de plus en plus
fréquente tout cas et notamment du
brillant sud africain donc on a bien
entendu les annonces de ce soir pour les
écoles visiblement ça n'est pas encore
tranchée d nous ce qu'on espère vraiment
c'est que ça ne sera plus vite on aurait
préféré une annonce directement ce soir
sera fermeture des écoles
malheureusement c'est une habitude de ce
gouvernement de les différer les
décisions a pu de faire attendre de
faire connaître ses décisions de l'état
victor o vous comprenez vous les
hésitations des gouvernements ça la
fermeture anticipée des écoles peut être
pour éviter de prendre de court les
parents et en temps je comprends plus
rien moi mathieu rice a raison c'est à
dire qu'on a un ministre de la santé qui
ne dit que c'est le département qu'elle
pu tester où il ya le plus de vaccins
et c'est là qu'elle plus de contaminer
avec un nouveau variant on est c'est
incompréhensible
franchement incompréhensible vous avez
un maire qui responsabilité quand même
de la sécurité des citoyens qui nous dit
je voudrais fermé parce que là on arrive
au bout et nord en fait on continue la
même chose et on change rien aux nommés
2000 vaccins en plus en sachant qu'il
faut un mois pour être immunisé je
comprends franchement pas médicalement
cette attitude de déni de la réalité sur
le terrain de cette pandémie
mathieu rice le gouvernement il va
poursuivre ses concertations pour
l'instant est ce que c'est un peu normal
quand même qu'ils prennent le temps de
réfléchir face à la situation qui
devient très inquiétante
dans grand test en moselle
particulièrement écouté je dirais
franchement que ça fait un an qu'on
discute et qu'on consulte à tout va il
ya un moment on ne peut plus discuter là
je pense que le ministre est venu se
rendre compte effectivement de la
réalité nous ça fait un an qu'on a les
mêmes revendications
ça fait un an qu'on demande un dépistage
systématique dans les écoles ça fait un
an qu'on demande des masques des
protections efficaces pour les
personnels je suis représentant mois des
personnels dédicacera seul faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants vont
travailler que des masques en tissu
alors que qu'on nous dit que les masque
en tissu sont plus suffisants face aux
variants nous on a des marques homologué
pour l'éducation nationale mais les
médecins n'arrête pas de nous dire que
les masques en tissu ne sont plus
suffisants pour protéger de ces
nouvelles formes du virus
nous on osait on a reçu nos masques avec
quatre semaines de retard en plus retour
des congés de noël
donc ça c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
pour vous en donner et à d'autres mais
on a l'impression d'un bricolage
constant depuis depuis plus d'un an
il ya des choses qui aurait pu être
réglé depuis bien longtemps et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans
l'urgence et on est encore incapable
dans l'urgence de prendre une décision
alors justement les deux victoires on
est vraiment dans l'urgence ce chiffre
que j'ai cités sans cas de variants par
jour la plupart sont sud africains selon
le ministre de la santé on nous répète
d'ailleurs que les variances beaucoup
plus contagieux que le govic classique
donc là il ya vraiment raison de d'être
dans l'urgence de prendre des décisions
rapidement
mais quand va t'on commencé à anticiper
le ministre de la santé nous dit qu'on
va nous mettre 2500 en plus il ya un
million d'habitants en moselle on peut
plus adhérer à ce jour dix courses et
terminer tous les voyants sont au rouge
en moselle qu'est ce qu'on fait rien de
plus qu en fait ce qu'on faisait avant
sur les 500 cas de variantes par jour ça
représente quoi concrètement en termes
d'évolution de l'aînée venus et serena
c'est sans cas qui ont été chercher on
est le pays où séquence le mois on est
le pays où on séquence le mois on va pas
chercher les variants là ils auront
trouvé mais en a dix fois plus est
je vous rappelle quand même que la
majorité des vaccins pour les commandes
à celle astrazeneca qui est pas efficace
sur le variant sud africain donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire la gueule
l'urgence dans l'es6 passion on ne
vaccine pas assez vite et manon nous
apprend qu'un vaccin qui sera pas
efficace sur ce qui a en terme de
pandémie sur la moselle
vous parlez du vaccin astrazeneca tout à
fait donc on sait pour l'instant elle
s'est pour l'instant le vaccin qui est
privilégiée puisque on attendait d'osier
le vaccin moderna vous avez cité
évidemment les 2012 supplémentaires
annoncées par olivier verrons cela
concerne aussi les offres
oui 2012 sur un million d'habitants vous
voyez pas un peu la différence qui a sur
un endroit où il ya 67 % des liens
domination qui sont cul par des patients
coville 19
il n'y a pas besoin d'être médecin il ya
juste besoin de raisonner un tout petit
peu et je pense que les mères qui
demande aujourd'hui cela c'est qu'ils
veulent protéger leurs populations
quand l'agression de mathieu risque
justement olivier ferrand il a annoncé
aussi un renforcement de la politique de
test ça concerne évidemment les écoles
ont sans doute aussi
mais moi aussi déjà si je peux me
permettre de rebondir simplement sur la
question des chiffres nous aussi on
constate ça fait un moment qu'on le
dénonce que les chiffres qu'on nous on
nous envoie son et qui sont publiées
dans les médias sont largement très
largement sous-estimé c'est un rapport
de 10 pour ce bonheur entre les vrais
chiffres
et puis les chiffres qu'on peut
constater que quand on nous renvoie on
l'a fait nous mêmes des statistiques qui
nous ont permis de montrer que l'écart
est énorme entre en soit ces chiffres
donc les gones n'est pas un lieu magique
comme on dit c'est de ne pas croire
depuis depuis quelques mois ou qui
s'arrête au portail on attend pour
rebondir sur les tests effectivement il
ya une volonté et pas simplement enfin
ça fait un an qu'on en parle
une volonté de mettre en place et est au
retour b les vacances des tests
salivaires et viennent d'être heures
quatre agrès hier mais dans la pratique
c'est encore très bien il a bien été
surtout les d'estampés de façon un petit
peu aléatoires à campagne de dépistage
on rentre dans une école on fire on
enterre tout le monde
éventuellement test en fonction des
symptômes est ce qu'il faudrait c'est
des thématiques mans tous les enfants
qui rentrent
l'école on va rentrer dans une phase où
on est en congé scolaire la seule ses
enfants vont retourner dans les familles
qui ont côtoyé des grands parents etc
si on fait rien aujourd'hui j'ai plus
face propager à vitesse variable sans
doute parce que l'ailé les nouveaux
variants qu'on a qu'on a chez nous
notamment se propage beaucoup plus
auprès des jeunes allant parce que j'ai
pas le mieux placé pour parler des coûts
côté médical mais vous avez les attentes
du virus en mai mais vous êtes le mieux
placé parce que y'a pas besoin d'être
médecin pour voir des chiffres et voir
la provocation
on parle de la moselle aujourd'hui et
moi je suis médecin c'est une femme née
on est à 9 % de positivité
vous croyez que ce virus et va s'arrêter
à la moselle quand leurs amis 2500 ou
3000 en moselle en attendant limpide on
en mettra puis sur les autres
départements
l'exemple de la moselle nous indiquer ça
vient toujours de l'est façon que ça va
venir comme ça depuis le début ou à
faire quoi va prendre les vaccins de la
moselle pour la mettant en scène samedi
non à un moment il faut anticiper et
cette anticipation qu'on n'a pas depuis
un an elle s'impose aujourd'hui je suis
désolé alors quand vous dites que ça
vient toujours de la moselle du grand
est c'est tellement un peu le même
scénario en termes d'évolution de
l'épidémie au mois de mars dernier on
s'en souvient oui bah oui parce que
c'est comme une zone frontalière
le virus passera pas par l'eau il
passera par la terre et les terres en
france sont plutôt à l'est qu'à l'ouest
donc c'est tout simplement une
propagation je vous rappelle que le
virus il lui faut un injecteur humain
c'est pas les poissons qui vont donner
le virus c'est forcément les humains
donc ça vient de l'ess c'est pas une
critique vis-à-vis des amis de l'est
c'est tout moment médical et ça viendra
comme on a fait vous rappeler pour
confiner à 18 heures on est parti de
l'est c'est finalement on a fait tout le
monde ça sera pareil ça passera de la
moselle ça ira dit souvent ça arrivera
en région parisienne et ça finira en
bretagne mais il n'y a pas besoin d'être
médecin et c'est évident c'est
l'histoire du virus et on essaie de nous
faire croire qu'aujourd'hui on va tester
un peu plus on va voir et ça va
s'arranger
non puisque ce variant ne fera
qu'augmenter et à modifier largement la
donne et les décisions à prendre
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
confiné au moins de façon localisée dans
le grand est maintenant parce que le
confinement
moan on ne veut pas entendre parler pour
l'instant l'exécutif n'ait gouvernement
matiériste et ce confinement je n'ai pas
d'avis spécialement en tout cas d'avis
syndicales et encore moins en tant que
représentant des personnels enseignants
fermer les écoles je pense que c'est
devenu une nécessité ça je pense que
j'ai pu m'exprimer là dessus après le
confinement dans ça notre problème on a
vu un couvre-feu à 18 heures en tout cas
qui qui n'a pas empêché la propagation
de virus ont été effectivement dans les
premiers départements être team
couvre-feu à 18 heures moi ya simplement
eu pour moi je voudrais faire sur les
contaminations regarde on a remarqué
pendant les fêtes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant les
vacances de noël les écoles et etterbeek
on a plus que le pic
on attendait alors que les gens fêter
les fêtes en famille c'est sans doute
qu'elles sont il ya une raison qui
explique qu'on soit rester sur un
plateau et que ça a explosé
alors à part les écoles il n'y a pas
cinquante mille possibilités
alors je parle du confinement parce que
c'est quand même une question qui va
très très vite se poser aux autorités
ludovic toro vu que effectivement la
circulation des variants laisse penser
que la situation empire de jour en jour
mais attention et et voilà qu'à prendre
un peu l'exemple des autres pays et
l'angleterre a eu un variant on est en
décalage et le mois nous arrivera la
même chose arrêtons de faire croire
qu'on est différent des autres d'accord
maintenant les les acteurs locaux les
maires demandent un confinement d'accord
donc il faut qu'on cinégénie ne font pas
par plaisir
vous croyez on a bien conscience du
problème à la fois sociétale à la fois
économique mais là ça y est la cei il ya
le nouveau variant qui va devenir en
plus majoritaires sur l'ancien qui était
quelque part un peu plus gentils parce
qu'elle est moins vite donc il faut
vraiment de vraies mesures devraient
mesure et vous avez raison en parlant
des enfants j'y pensais mais on a
toujours dit vous savez qui le début des
enfants sont pas contaminant par
contagieux c'est tout le contraire
la différence c'est qu'ils sont
asymptomatiques c'est à dire qu'on voit
pas connaissons malade et est votre
analyse est très bonne par rapport à ça
on a toujours nié tout ça pour des
raisons autres que des raisons de santé
d'accord et que maintenant il faut quand
même prendre des vraies mesures sur des
faits et des chiffres et on voit bien
qu'en moselle les faits et les chiffres
sont présents et les annonces du
du ministre la santé nos pas me
satisfaire au point de vue médical ça
c'est une chose certaine vous avez posé
une question importante en matière de
stratégie de lutte quand vous parliez du
vaccin tout à l'heure astrazeneca acte
n'est pas efficace en tout cas selon
certaines études face aux variants à
jour je vous rappelle qu en afrique du
sud
non seulement les bichiques asthme et
hippiques pas c'est à dire qu'à afrique
du sud quelle variante à sud africain a
décidé de ne pas mettre ce vaccin ne pas
vacciner les gens avec ça tandis que
nous c'est en fait le pilot vaccins
qu'on a commandé ses astra zeneca merci
beaucoup à vous ludovic toro médecin
membre du collectif c 19 mai rude et de
coubron merci à vous maturi ce
professeur des écoles secrétaire du
snudi fo de moselle